alright and this is too young with this
lemming guy who should have been really
annoying really fast but I was shocked I
was actually really laughing which is so
hard to do to make something where it's
like there's that much yelling it's very
hard to balance that they do a
surprisingly good job with it though
like until they see how someone could be
really annoying but like I thought it
was funny I really enjoyed it
um but this focus is on Finn and bubble
gum bubble gum the first episode
dressing after you know is she watched
some age and and they're both the same
age and because she's too young this was
he called Lennon Landgraf the Lemongrab
comes as his really loud creation that
she made and he assumes the throne
because she's too young and he's a
tight-ass and puts everyone in prison
for like millions of years and stuff and
so I was gonna say Finn to Jake Finn and
bubblegum guts
okay in a second though they they do
sort of like act like you know Finn and
Jake and how mischievous they are and
you know and they're trying to pull
pranks and stuff like that and they get
thrown in prison and so the only way to
get around it is that she has to she has
to put the age back on and they do it
through some sort of was it a jolly to
you or what did they call it something
like that and they take a bunch of the
candy put together and only like a big
hug can I get her back to 18 and she
gets back to 18 she's not interested
Finn and so five years ago yeah that's
so five years ago which is a good line
and Jake is like you know you gotta be
persistent and Finn's like okay I'll be
persistent um yeah I'm not gonna lie
it's like I really understand what you
were saying now because her at 13 what's
great yeah and I was like oh my god I'm
really gonna love this new bubblegum
like this is really great
one episode she goes back and it's like
it's so strange because they say
everything about what's wrong with her
being that age and why being her thing
this age is good and that she just goes
back to that age I'm like dude they
should just kept her at that age and
Finn was having fun and there's actually
like a legit
you know Romeo sampling she was doing
stuff hey you know I do as part of the
adventure and stuff and it's like yeah
I'm just like they should have kept her
13 I don't know what they're gonna do
with it but or if they are gonna have
something more fun with it but it's like
how I really sympathize because she was
so much more fun when she was his age so
yeah I just I want something to blow her
up again so she could go back to back I
think it was disturbing when all her
candy people were like put them together
it was it's all for love for one I love
the fact that when you know Finn is all
upset that Peebles is going to be
turning back to 18 she's saying it's
nice to be a kid again I she's basically
saying I hate being grown up and all the
responsibilities I have and it's great
being 13 but this is a point in time
where my people actually need me and my
people are more important than my own
happiness and in return the candy people
are like you know what in a sense like
our body is worth more than what the
crap you know if the town is going
through compels you do it by nowadays
standards let's say some town any town
is going through some crisis and the
only way for this time to survive is for
people to literally cut off a chunk of
their flesh and give it to like give it
to the mayor or whatever how many people
do you think would actually willingly
give up that and go through pain I don't
think the candy people go through pain
okay special spicy oh so just their eyes
hurt initially the one who literally
broke off this part of his face but they
were still smiling they didn't want to
be in the dungeon for a million years
think about it I okay though I'm kind of
sad I wish we could see more lemon tell
me there's more lemongrass there's more
lemon grab is there really are you just
saying that I'll say this okay who - so
I'll say give me numerous things I mean
lemongrab the sequel actually be more
like this would be like this and this
and this done like that well thanks for
clarifying that
no no no I just guess I really like the
episode I like her at that age and even
if they did have to go back to her being
older like I will not understand
especially because it it sounds like the
guy different voice actress but maybe
just fed up the voice but it's not like
a real little kid and I I will say in
this episode though I did understand
more because I was always sort of like
she's 18 like she didn't act like she
was 18 but like when she switches back
and she's like double his height it is
her like oh yeah maybe I'm seeing now
more why this is like really awkward and
stuff cuz it's like I said that the age
is really cemented in that one envisions
like oh yeah okay cuz you just sort of
assume like she's tall and fits short or
something but it's like no like she
actually is older and that would be a
little weird yeah just like it's that
doesn't be different age wise age at 13
which is why I think you know a million
and thirteen marcelina Finn would just
go better you know you know she's she's
18 and too old you know I just think a
million it's it's such an age gap that
it's like it's so far that as you saw it
comes around again to being okay so that
that's my theory on that I agree they
did stuff it's like
just really miss it cuz it's like I like
I like the science nerd aspect I like
that that's kind of fun you know with uh
with the bubblegum character you don't
sometimes you can have a good line but
it's like she's mostly just kind of a
bore we're like and like I said we're
Marceline and Finn would do stuff you
know and have fun and go on adventures
and stuff it's like that's fun and here
like she was starting to do that cuz she
was you know I guess more of a little
kid I get what you're saying to about
like the responsibility running the
kingdom a it's like I got the idea but
it's just it's so signifying why it's
just not fun baby I know it's like the
idea to a drama that's part of it but I
don't know well and to if you think
about it she had to be 18 because if if
she stayed 13 her and Finn would be
boyfriend and girlfriend for real all
right what do boyfriend and girlfriend
usually do they spend all their time
together so where would adventure time
come from there wouldn't be many
adventures you know what they would
always be in in the Candy Kingdom doing
silly little 13 year old pranks I don't
know some cool stuff there's like as the
first ones like a zombie episode with
zombie candy yes she was 18 remember
we're talking about if she stayed 13 way
too much logic in a show about candy
people I just want to say this I find
very interesting when when Peebles goes
a little bit bonkers and like does
something bizarre or weird people
instantly go like she's a bitch or what
the hell's wrong with her you know this
anything but Marceline can literally do
whatever she wants turned into a giant
demon and beat the hell out of Finn
and/or Jake and it's acceptable okay you
can start the character but that's what
I'm saying that's what Marceline is one
bubblegum who you see specifically in
this episode saying how much she hates
being a teen and having to consistently
rule over this kingdom flips out you
know it's like oh she's just a bitch
well maybe she's getting out some of
that pent-up rage or some of that anger
that she has to hold in okay hold on if
that's the case they could show that
better oh no no no and honestly when she
went nuts
I was actually identified the character
more fun if she went crazy
more often honest no I'm fine with that
my prize that she's way to like sort of
the typical pretty princess
bland not interesting and stuff I know
like I said with the exception of the
science aspect I like that I like the
geek aspect
um but yeah everything else is just too
you know safe and bland you know it when
she was going nuts outside you kind of
excited like oh wow this is gonna be
like just sort of a thing with her like
she just goes and say or that one
episode where she was like it was if she
was like trapping the Ice King or
whatever like there's this you know like
oh my gosh there's just like this crazy
psychotic working under this but then
that was kind of explained it's like I
was actually lucky that angled more if
they went more with that but I know
she's not awful I mean cuz it's like you
can't see she does level out you know
the fact that it Finn is just so I don't
wanna say brainless but like with his
violence but that you know he does need
that sensitive side to sort of like
level amount sometimes which we've seen
her do another episode but it's kind of
like I don't know it seemed like it
still leveled him out in this episode
like the emotional side with her and
they got along better it it just seems
so much better I just I was really
getting excited cuz I'm like man these
episodes are gonna be so much more fun
with her at this age okay all I'm gonna
say is this that I will be done
they're both 13 how do they solve the
situation breaking and did that solve
the situation in any way shape so how
exciting would that have been for two
idiots to run around in all the Kingdom
or kind of rule the King on only they
couldn't cuz they're already thrown in
jail like halfway through the episode
and they were actually in jail it's an
episode where a dog can change into
anything it's that that's the show
that's what I'm saying is that I think
it was just a 213 she's robbing the King
don't run the house the king or queen
hey why don't they do their job I love
the fact that they take bubble gum and
they turn her into a kid and that's all
they do they don't go down the Olsson
the adult route one thing
start getting serious quote-unquote they
still stick to that angle of oh we can
deal with this by pranking him oh oh
okay that bring didn't work what can we
do
oh people are thrown in jail for 17
years we'll prank him harder like they
don't actually try to solve the
situation well I mean she eventually
does well yeah
but again yeah you can serve me like
what she has both serve having been 18
and now being 13 yeah it is or it makes
sense she could balance that out more
you know I feel like her first order of
business not that she's back to being 18
is to fix Lemongrab in case something
happens again it's simple we don't know
the ology thing you learn you will
actually learn we've got some insight in
terms of how to add age but ya know it's
a good I like seeing her that age and I
understand what they're doing at the end
and it does work enough you know that
she should be back to the age and stuff
but when you see like he I don't know
honestly what you start broken up I was
kind of like yeah stay this time stay
broken I feel like he's gonna go back
it's like ah so I don't know I don't
hated I just feel like there's more fun
to be had somewhere else if you gave him
like a different girlfriend
I seen the problem with honestly as much
as I say how cool it'd be with him the
Marceline hooking up like I do see the
problem with it but it just be more fun
it's just it's it's like once I just
like you know know this is what the
character needs and deserves on the
other hand I'm like just entertainment
so it's it's tough to say but not still
still get up a soda closing thoughts
I want more Lemongrab and I don't know
what it is you're absolutely right he
should really be the most annoying damn
thing and I know he's supposed to be
really annoying but any time he starts
opening his mouth and whining I just I
cracked the hell up yeah there's
something there's something about the
way he does
I think it's even the animation of his
face along with the whining yeah I think
it over
even the build-up of a few things I mean
it's just it's just so much frustration
that he can't keep bottle I I don't know
maybe that's it you can understand grab
inside her little brain yeah there's
just something about the way he
expresses and they build it up and stuff
that's very effective so how about you
share with the class
oh I already shared my thoughts I don't
care you know you're not high pitched in
like annoying enough yet I will take
that as a compliment
yeah I'm gonna leave before I get kicked
out oh-ho in your face you're grounded
no you're grounded yes ma'am
two weeks dungeon both of you hey rule
oh the next episode is the monster by
the way that's why segue